[Music]
william yes dom we have returned well
where did we go um i don't know where we
went actually but we've uh we were just
talking about musicals then you've
you've been having a musical
extravaganza haven't you on the east
coast of the united states i'm alexander
hamilton oh
i'm alexander hamilton
see and so he introduced himself do the
rap one
[Music]
hey if i put a pencil to my thinking and
i'm burning banner hey then i thought
about something then i made america
along with these guys oh but then you
shoot me i'll put my hand in the air
sometimes that doesn't stop them i
should have been beatboxing might have
that yeah they've been good
hey are you alexander burr
no you're playing alexander bar oh no
it's not going to burn i don't think
that's weird alexander
somebody else
i'm john adams and i've got no hair
president united states i don't care
i'm alexander hamilton
oh you've jumped to barry sunday didn't
he he enjoyed it though didn't it that
that song is quiet uptown really makes
me upset yeah he moves uptown uptown uh
upstate new york would that be right or
away from manhattan
was there even a manhattan i don't know
but he moves away from all the people
because he just wants to walk around and
grieve with his wife well yeah because
he's always been
with everybody you know
in the room where it happens room where
it happens room where it happens
it happens
that's all for on this why is it it's
just this thing about america what would
be your rap name if you could pick one
keep in mind that you're a very famous
scotsman what about leaned over hey that
would be our name
m.c leaned over oh that's good yeah
little lean nova what would yours be
the dominator oh that's fantastic i'm
the dominator and i've got stuff
things to say
i say i'm quite rough lovely listen to
all the words that i say
say say say that's a word say
say i'm a natural rapper try not to
worry about it um
oh i've got a song for you
i was thinking of this on the way in and
i thought i wonder if billy can can get
this from the tune ready
it's from a famous tv show
get it
[Music]
[Music]
grange hill you will never believe this
in a thousand years don't tell me you're
in it i will not tell you i was that
thank god i was talking to my wife this
morning yeah
i can't remember what about and grinch
he'll come up really that is crazy
really i swear to you that's nuts i was
telling my i think i was talking about
you know when you get a tv show or
whatever and really into it and i wrote
to one of the girls in grange hell i
wrote to the guy i watched the guy ran
it but what so you wrote to who
the girl who created suzanne and i wrote
to tell her that i had a crush on her oh
lovely and one of my friends from school
wrote to a friend
they never wrote back well i wrote to
phil mcintyre who created grandchill and
later on create brookside a relatively
famous liverpudlian um showrunner
and i got what what i think now must
have been the standard letter back yeah
but it like i i read it i don't know how
many times so it's basically like you
know dear dominic thank you very much
for your inquiry we actually uh look for
young boys and girls in and around the
the school districts of london
but good luck with everything in your
career and i look forward to seeing what
you do as a professional actor type
thing and i probably looked at that
letter a thousand times as a kid and
thought wow the guy they actually they
were thinking about me
they were is that what you were thinking
yeah they were thinking about me they
were considering me and they just said
you know what i'm gonna go in a
different direction it was for young
kids
the show to watch for what eight ten
years or something i loved it it was
brilliant it uh tucker tucker's luck he
had a spin-off didn't he yeah he got a
spin-off and his mate was called parky
and he
dealt with some quite
hard-hitting issues drug abuse and that
was all kind of later on was you know
yes ammo was there yeah but i i kind of
liked it when it
wasn't about that when it was just about
people throwing sausages across the
canteen yeah which was more like my
school you know oh yeah but oh that's
funny bro that's crazy do you can you
see inside my living room or something
in the morning i think i can see inside
your brain i'd rather you didn't you
mine don't look in there
peeling the onion
hey should we do a little bit of
housekeeping
[Applause]
how much fun are you
to keep a house so clean and true
what you got done shall i go or should
you go yeah you go okay here we go this
is a uh wonderful message from aaron in
oregon
oregon i don't know do you know dominic
f my hand yeah what a map of the united
states of america yeah this being my
thumb being florida yeah california over
here yeah new york up the top there yeah
where would you find oregon it's
portland isn't it but oh yes
i'm going to say you know where
california is i'm going to say just a
little bit above califor what happened
my watch was failing yeah i think it's
just above california
one up from california
yeah john
oregon portland oregon is it one up from
california
yes it is
you didn't know that you had yeah i was
waiting i want to make sure i had some
microphone juice oh all right
did you know that i did i went there uh
last year for thanksgiving and it's
about a 16-hour drive from eugene to
santa monica lovely well 16 hour drive
and what's your favorite favorite
restaurant in oregon john oh uh it was
during covet so we didn't go to many
restaurants um but oh voodoo donuts
though
i've had a voodoo doughnut a tiny little
doll in the center yeah and if you bait
it somebody somewhere loses a leg
anyway lovely aaron from oregon has
written in regards to league of legends
oh yes
said i've been wanting to know if dom
and billy ever play the a-ram mode if so
what are your thoughts that's the only
mode i play these days and i much prefer
it matches it typically quicker you get
to try out a wide range of champs bonus
tip mute everyone that isn't your friend
for a better experience in case you
didn't know a ram stands for all random
all middle in a nutshell everyone gets a
random champ from the ones that they own
and you fight out in a single lane so
it's basically mid lane we've played it
we played it you and nigel liked it i i
disliked it quite quite a lot yes but i
would say this is back in your more
um rubbish less confident days i hear
you it's just an all-out brawl it goes
faster the games are about 15 minutes so
sometimes we'll play a couple of major
games and then we're like i don't really
have time for a full game oh let's just
have a quick a room
yeah i just felt like it was a lot of
colors and a lot of people doing stuff
but i had no idea what was going on and
there was no skill involved i understand
i didn't enjoy it just pressing a bunch
of buttons well thank you aaron for your
lovely inquiry
and maybe i'll try it again know that
i'm slightly better i'm here to tell you
about green chef fantastic company they
will send you out food with the recipes
and you get in the kitchen and you get
working and they make it all very easy
because green chef pre-made and
pre-measured sauces dressing spices it
gets you that chef curated flavor
without all the hassle of buying all the
little bits that you'll never use again
and they make it much easier to
customize than ever before so you can
swap the proteins say you want chicken
or beef and it's all usda certified or
wild caught sockeye sam and you can swap
that around and all the new ingredients
recipes delicious meals that support a
healthy lifestyle elevate your dinner
experience with the fall finest
collection a curated selection of
farmstead favorites fresh seasonal
ingredients and premium protein sounds
fantastic
green chef is the number one meal kit
for eating well with dinners that work
for you not the other way round go to
greenchef.com135 and use the code
onion135 to get 135
off across five boxes and your first box
ships free so you just go to
greenchef.com135
and use the code onion135 and you get
135 off across five boxes and your first
box ships free green chef the number one
meal kit for eating well
now who doesn't love cereal well we all
love cereal it's fantastic you can do a
whole box in a sitting easy but as we
get older we realize it's maybe not that
good for you it's a lot of sugar a lot
of stuff you shouldn't be eating well
somebody has fixed that they've changed
the game and it's magic spoon they've
worked out how you get that great flavor
and great texture without all the bad
stuff it's packed with protein so if you
come back from the gym or a hike you can
have magic spoon as a healthy snack or
that midnight snack that you want
there's a flavor for everyone now let me
tell you some of this there's zero grams
of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and
only 45 net grams of carbs in each
serving it's low carb it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free and only
140 calories a serving you can build
your own box with all the different
flavors this cocoa and fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry muffin maple
waffle oh yes honey nut you can mix it
all up it's fantastic just go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and try the magic for yourself
and be sure to use our promo code onion
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order and magic spin is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
rihanna from sioux city iowa hello
imagine you're having a dinner party
right you can invite three people in
addition to your friends and family how
lovely
you can each invite one person who is
alive
who you've not had the pleasure of
meeting one person who is deceased but
brought back to life and one fictional
character who would you invite what
would you talk about what would you
serve at the party are we at the same
dinner party are these are separate um
dinner
is way too much to have all those people
okay you need a giant table so one
person alive i would have
uh
jane goodall the
incredible
uh wildlife worker naturalist who's
who's done a huge amount of work on uh
primates specifically chimps have you
ever met her i have had dinner with her
hold on yeah
i'll just re-read this to you though
yeah
one person who is alive whom you haven't
had the pleasure of meeting
so david attenborough
i have not met sir dave
but i have had dinner with jane goodall
and she is lovely oh lovely could not
have been nicer well
one critique if i may god would have
liked to have spoke to her for her to
have spoken up a little bit
there was a lot of very quietly yeah i
was like what was that probably because
she's trying not to um wake the chicks
scared gorillas
yeah chimps but yeah and gorillas yeah
occasionally
not usually
i mean of course i'm sure she's worked
with some gorillas but she's made very
famous for her work with chimps it was
diane fosse who was famous for
gorillas gorillas in the midst of course
and a great choreographer
yeah brilliant yeah okay should we do it
at the same time not the same time all
right so you do your life okay so you've
done your live personally
yeah it's a day and i'll go
for
tom cruise
really my favorite i want to talk to him
about maverick not only not only uh the
film maverick but a maverick choice by
you thank you brilliant okay and then
who we got next one person who is
deceased brought back to life well you
know what i'm gonna say don't you you
can answer for me
uh john lennon no what no come on i've
answered it a bunch of times in the same
way have you i've very still done wasn't
you yeah good point buddha i would have
the buddha i think he's for my money
he's the most fascinating human that's
ever lived can i just check something on
this when we bring them back and he says
they're brought back to life they're not
zombies right i don't think they're the
undead right so they're brought back as
well okay
then how about you well you put you you
put a thought in my head i'll go for um
paramahansa yogananda bless you thank
you
brilliant choice so basically another
environment
yeah just to talk about enlightenment
and what that means and
okay very good another fantastic uh uh
historical character and one fictional
character
and they show up obviously as that
fictional character it's not like
harrison ford playing han solo and then
he shifts harrison ford he would be han
solo the entire time yes yes
would be handful
so with all the history and baggage of
hansel
that's a tough one um
well i've done two relatively serious
earnest people sir david attenborough
the buddha so i think i'm looking for a
tonic and i would maybe go for someone
like bugs bunny
just to see you know just to see what
that does to the parrot yeah the
chemistry do you know i mean the alchemy
okay that's quite good then what about
you superman you've got tom cruise there
you're aware of that just letting you
know there could be there could be a
conflict
who's who's the leading man sort of
thing who is the real superman but saint
is superman
i mean he's overpowered superman isn't
he
i'd like to know what that feels like
to be overpowered all the time lovely
choices thank you well can i add to this
yeah oh no this is part of it yeah what
would you say at the party there's one
before that wasn't it was it well what
would you talk to them about oh well i
mean it's just open it's an open
conversation i mean you you wouldn't
you'd you let the the conversation flow
yeah like the friendship onion yeah you
wouldn't you wouldn't dictate to the
buddha no no no no no no i don't want
you to talk about that provide us with
your wisdom and you couldn't with
superman
he'd zap you with his laser eyes
yeah so we talk about whatever comes up
and what would you serve at the party
well that's a good one because i would
think the buddha and paramahansa
yogananda i would think would be
vegetarian
vegetarian
i think he's quite healthy right he
lives in the gym and stuff oh he
definitely lifts yeah i would serve for
david sir david attenborough the buddha
and bugs bunny because bugs bunny's also
vegetarian
i'd serve a kind of middle eastern
platter with carrots carrots hummus
baba ganoush
maybe some uh pita bread some carrots
some pickles
rice nice vegetable maybe a greek salad
right that's what i'd do keep it simple
yeah i mean it's more difficult with
superman and paramahansa and
tom cruise i would say outside of parma
hanza i think you probably i think you
might get some complaints for your guess
if there wasn't a little bit of protein
i think tom cruise is a heavy protein
eater well maybe we could ask tom to
bring a chef
because then that's tom dealt with
and then i'm sure they could adapt for
the other two lovely
good that was a good question that was a
great question rihanna um should we do
one more go on tom
amy from breckenridge in colorado we've
been to colorado you and i yeah had a
great time there lovely says if you
could have a live podcast anywhere in
the world
where would it be and how can we make
that happen well
we have been very lucky over the last
kind of year or so
to have been able to go
all over the united states and kind of
do it with our podcast and i'm hoping
that that
turns into maybe a little bit of a
worldwide thing i hope so because i've
really enjoyed this me too i'd like a
podcast in glasgow i'd like one in
london i'd like one in paris i'd like
one in sydney australia and then you
talk about the stuff of that place
exactly and the first thing that comes
to my mind is a food
always
and uh so for me
i'd like to do in japan
and maybe in a sort of food market in
japan and be quite loud
john would have a hard time making sure
that the mics were working okay in in
that but
i reckon in a food market in japan
and it's all
almost the whole
episode is a billion dollar meet the
world
but we talk about japan and history and
all that during it and uh we'll bring on
some guests but mainly we're eating
japanese food all the way through yeah
every five to ten minutes or so another
little plate is brought forward try this
this is a local delicacy this is great
that'd be good i like that all those
places that i mentioned but if i'm gonna
pick one i mean wellington would be
pretty great we spent a lot of time in
wellington we have a lot of really
amazing memories there we could go to a
place that we used to frequent back in
the day
and uh
just walk up and down the streets of
wellington and think about that time
when we used to be princess and now
we're kind of exiled all the kings they
probably wouldn't want us back yeah
well done for doing um one answer to
that
it's the first time you've ever done
that yeah well i've listened to you you
did you did say the other day that
unfortunately when someone asked me for
one answer i usually give three which is
true
don't yeah voicemails let's do them
later have we got any voicemails john
hello my name is anastasia i'm from
pittsburgh pennsylvania in the united
states
i have only just started listening to
the podcast unfortunately
i only just found out about it so i may
be a bit behind but i'm on episode two
listening to you discuss
a kind of abs lib i know that's not the
right word that you said pete jackson
really enjoyed in the lord of the rings
where
um
billy i think it was had a balloon
under the blanket during the pelantier
scene
and everybody thought it was really
funny you kind of just made that up as
you went
my question was were there any other
scenes that you guys kind of came up
with weren't scripted and they made it
into the movies
good question tom i remember in that
palantir um scene as well
um
i was supposed to take the palantir from
ian mckellen's sleeping
arms and he he sleeps with his eyes open
you know and i was to go over and take
the pantier and i i said to pete i
thought i thought it'd be quite fun if
we did a little match to um
raiders of the lost ark
so that when i took it i replaced it
with something else
yeah it was like a jug next there was a
water jug that had a kind of round
bottom i suppose like a volunteer so as
i took the palantir out i replaced it
with a thing
i was a little i was a little nod to uh
raiders i think in quite a few of the
sequences with tree beard there was a
few little things that we had said well
what about this is a little flourish and
pete was like yeah do it i think when
when i wake up when mary wakes up and
realizes that you've been drinking the
end draft and you're taller yeah is it i
don't think it was scripted that you
have kind of like
indigestion right yeah i don't think so
yeah like you've still got it going on
and
i think a lot of that scene obviously
scripted but the little looks towards
each other and you know
who's bigger
yeah
little little bits and pieces like that
were obviously um
improvised i just remembered one then
and now i can't remember
that that line from um that part where
we're trying to get
the ants to go south and i say the
closer we are to danger the further we
are from harm that was ad-libbed oh
great yeah lovely you like that yeah i
love that
thank you very much is there another one
john
hi my name is olivia i'm from the
chicago area and my question is for
dominic
so dominic what is it about apples that
you love so much is it the crunch is it
the tartness i'm interested in hearing
um why you love apples so much
that's a good question it's a lovely
it's very simple question well it's
about apples isn't it yeah and i mean
even you could take right back to adam
and eve you could couldn't you yeah
there's the fruit of temptation exactly
so why do you like apples i grew up on
apples my mom is a big apple fan still
eats apples almost every time maureen's
coming back from the kitchen she got an
apple in her hand you know and she likes
to eat with a knife and a plate now well
does she yeah she likes to chop into it
i think you know
i wouldn't assume about my mother but i
think as you get older maybe you're a
little worried about
your teeth coming out with a bite it
does sometimes takes a bit yeah and i do
like to eat an apple with a knife but i
like to do it like i'm a cowboy oh yeah
yeah
i mean i don't want a plate i want to
have a little knife i understand that
you make little discs little spheres
um so i grew up with apples is the first
question a lot of times the things that
you grow with you know you just just
part not as my family members i just
thought they were gwyneth paltrow's
pro a daughter probably says i grew up
with apples isn't one of them called
apple yeah yeah absolutely
just made me laugh yeah
i thought you meant i thought you were
laughing because you thought when i said
i grew up with apples you were like oh
your dad's an apple your mum's an apple
no no i was just thinking you sound like
one of goodness paltrow's kids
so there's that
i think apple's we've we've you've heard
me talk about this quite a lot i think
apple's
probably the most underrated fruit in
the west because
they're ubiquitous like an orange or a
banana which i mean i remember my dad
saying as a kid bananas weren't around
when he was a kid and then suddenly
everyone was like oh here's a new fruit
it's a banana and my dad said like first
time he saw a pineapple he's in his like
30s or something do you know what i mean
so these are things that we're used to
but obviously
the apple has been around for so long
you can fit it in your pocket no problem
you can travel with it there's a bunch
of different varieties my favorite
probably classically is the granny smith
although i do love a pink lady i know
you do i like a gala i like i think
they're called reddits
tiny little apples they're about that
big it's like five or six bites
good for you
a good source of sugar a good source of
potassium i believe and
the
active there's an active ingredient
inside the apple which i believe is
called pectin but if i'm wrong please
let me know
which uh dilates the gallbladder
exhaust valve essentially and allows any
uh bits and pieces to fall out because
the pipe is a little bigger than normal
so
hopefully
i won't have any gallstones which you
can attest are quite painful very
painful and uh i'll tell you it's not
pectin it begins with a bee
but i can't remember what it is
because when you're trying to get rid of
them naturally you you drink a lot of
apple juice and all that to do that
bro
bro
well no it's not brad pitt
bromelain i think is in pineapples now
what about you because you like an apple
but it's not it's not your favorite
fruit obviously no what would you give
it out of 10
oh i'd definitely give that name oh you
love an apple oh an apples great but
it's just you know
there's only so many times i can eat
during the day
and i don't know if i'd choose an apple
as one of those times so what would be
what would you say if you take a
cross-section of your life so far
what would be the top of your list for
an inter meal snack
fruit or anything banana fruit or
anything anything
i mean it wouldn't be healthy if i had
the choice
yeah i just mean what is it not if you
had the choice what has it been cereal
oh that's not bad no it's not great why
well cereal is mainly sugar isn't it oh
you're eating sugary cereal no i'm
eating the good stuff i'm no but and you
know historically i wouldn't have been
like frosties and cocoa pops and stuff
yeah a lot of that stuff too
but if it was if it was fruit it'd be a
banana
i love a banana mine would be my average
snack across all of the years of my life
would be an apple and i think probably
second would be a handful of almonds
love a handful of almonds see how i
wouldn't be my go-to nut either ah well
she was a pistachio cashew
that's my i think that would be my dad's
favorite now what i like to do with the
raw almonds
i'll take three right one will sit right
in the center of course one will get
shoved up into the top of my right
gum i want to get shoved up into the top
of my right gum and i'll let those
soften as i'm eating this guy and then
when i pull these down
in my mouth i'll halve them and i'll
shell them in my mouth of course you
will
eat the skin first yeah on both sides
and then i'll eat the knot and sometimes
i'll sliver the nut so it becomes like
little slices within your mouth yeah
within my mouth that's technical though
yeah i'm dexterous
do you know that's what um
the it was the main actor and godfather
marlon brenda that's what he was doing
all right that's why his mouth was funny
in those movies
he was de-shelling nuts
coming to my house but
you know for respect don't give me
friendship you
you don't even think to call my
godfather
michael come here michael michael
michael
i always thought i always thought we had
more time michael it's okay pop
this um will come and say
i took care of it pop
hey i just remembered then in terms of a
dexterous uh mouth yeah
liv tyler can still
tie a cherry stem into a knot
oh yeah remember she did it in new
zealand for us a few times
and on her recent birthday she did it on
instagram and i wrote and i said i can't
believe you still have that skill and
she was like yeah i'm really good at it
i can take the laces out of a nike
running shoe
tie them in my mouth
put them back in the shoe again we're
going to bring on our illustrious guests
wait till you see this one dom have you
had lunch because this is uh quite a
heavy
uh eating based podcast today dominic
our guest today we've got an absolutely
fantastic guest i'll give you a little
background
smoking ed curry as an american chili
pepper breeder
he is the founder and president of the
pucker butt
pepper company he's best known maybe for
breeding the hottest chili pepper in the
world and its name is dom carolina
it's called the carolina reaper and it
was recognized by the guinness world
records as the hottest uh chili pepper
in the world curry was born in west
bloomfield township in michigan uh and
in 2001 curry moved to south carolina
where we will find him today where he
began growing his own peppers in the
yard and experimenting with crossbreeds
which i'm really interested in hearing
how that works
yeah he was featured in the episode
chili eating in the 2020 netflix
documentary series we are the champions
fantastic well here's ed hi ed how's it
going hello smoking ed curry
well hello there it's going great man
i'm excited to be on the show we're
excited to have you billy and i enjoy
hot food i don't know if we enjoy this
level of hot but we like spicy we do
like spicy and um
you know chili peppers being my go-to i
would think if i'm if i'm putting any
heat into something so um we're very
excited to talk to you today ed thank
you for coming on
awesome you're welcome thank you for
having me in one of our earlier episodes
of this show ed we were recommended by
our producer to eat um giardina from uh
chicago have you do you like chardonnay
or have you ever been exposed to it
i was just in chicago about four weeks
ago and i helped myself to quite a bit
nice
yeah there there really isn't anything
uh chili that i'm not very fond of
and
the relishes are really good so you like
to have something hot in almost all of
your meals every day would that be fair
i start my day with some pepper oil in
my coffee just to get myself lit up and
going oh wow
do you know i had jardiner last night we
were away for the weekend and i got in
last night and there was nothing in the
house to eat and i thought i'm just
going to get a pizza you know and i just
got a pizza and i got a jar of
giardiniera and i must have been through
about half of it
it's probably my favorite thing we've
had on this show yet it's so good on a
pizza oh it just makes it so good well
ed let's
let's take it back we always like to
kind of explore the origin story of our
superhero guest that we have on so let's
let's take it way back and try and find
out exactly
at what point in your life did you think
i'm a huge fan of spicy and i'm going to
make a career out of that
well back in 1981 my family dropped me
off of college they told me i was going
to die of heart disease or cancer and i
better do something about it if i wanted
to keep partying like i was
you know so i started doing research in
a thing called the library
and that led me to chili peppers the
indigenous populations
around the equator
they have very low indices of heart
disease or cancer even when they're
westernized uh so
i decided i needed to find some really
hot chilis and i went to a vietnamese
restaurant it was i think the only
vietnamese restaurant in michigan at the
time
and i asked them for the hottest thing
they had and then they just had fun with
me for like two hours right but from
that point forward i was hooked um and
after after all the research that you've
done and stuff is that a true thing is
that
eating chilis does help with heart
disease and
it helps with a ton of different
diseases there's a lot of
research we've turned all our stuff over
to the medical field there's a lot of
research going on there's a key on a sub
capsuloid that fits into a cancer cell
it causes an autoimmune sequence that
kills the cell
the problem is the delivery method
not very many people want to eat
carolina reapers or or something super
hot all day long uh but you know like
all your uh sport screams and bengay and
things like that they're all based in
capsaicin it's a natural pain reliever
it's also it naturally oxidizes the
bloodstream uh so
there's research going on with heart
disease cancer als weight loss all sorts
of stuff would it be fair to say that
exposing yourself to
chili's
raises your endorphin levels at the same
time because of the pain
oh yeah yeah well it's see the reaction
the body has with capsaicin is a
chemical reaction our brain perceives as
heat
some of the
natural defenses to that perception
are the endorphin rush and the dopamine
rush seek they also fill the dopamine
receptors in your brain and give you a
russia kind of akin to a runner's high
only i think it's quite a bit more than
a runner's eye
and every time you eat it you get that
same rush
so uh some of us who are like i i am an
ex-addict i'm in recovery now almost 24
years uh but i catch a good buzz on
peppers every single day you know well
with that i just can't be arrested for
it
yeah that's great that's great that
you've found paul it's fantastic so with
that in mind ed just tell us what your
average breakfast lunch and dinner might
might be
okay well i in the morning i just drink
coffee and i put that pepper oil in
coffee
and then if i do happen to eat anything
at lunch it always has peppers and hot
sauce on it but normally during the day
i don't eat it all but i i i'm much you
know i have the biggest pep hot pepper
farm in the united states i spend my
whole day playing with peppers
and when i see something i might have to
take a bite so i'm lighting myself up
all day long and then drinking more cold
coffee and lightening and drinking so by
the time i get home to have some dinner
i'm shaking like a week
you know
and then
every day
yeah well you know i i i don't look
healthy anymore because i you know kovac
kind of locked us down but i used to do
karate five times a week
you know i just i enjoy
uh outside activity and uh you know
dinner time for us is nothing but hot
whatever we're having anything we're
having it's hot sauce and slices of
pepper you know i i don't recommend ever
eating a pepper hole because it's not a
pleasant experience i only do it now for
tv or for you know interviews such like
that yeah
but when you slice them up and include
it in your meal yeah it just it elevates
everything that you're eating yeah
you know we've even gotten to the point
where we've uh sprinkled pepper powder
into cereal just to see what was going
on
and you know there's some cereals it
just doesn't match with but some cereals
it does yeah
absolutely so so you're having this meal
in michigan
and um
vietnamese or whatever it was restaurant
with some
hot peppers but that obviously didn't
lead you straight away to getting a farm
in in south carolina so how where did
you go from there
well like i said i i was an addict so
uh i dabbled in and out of peppers all
through the 80s and 90s we grew them in
the yard i grew stuff that people never
saw right
back then we didn't have the internet so
i'd send like
letters to different countries they're
agricultural ministries and ask for
pepper seeds you know and what i got
back
whatever they called it i'd start
growing it and gradually i found hotter
and hotter and hotter peppers
it wasn't really until i got clean
that
you know i really got serious about
growing this stuff
uh and then when i moved down here the
carolinas are just the perfect place
to grow any spice in the world we have
the right soil the right temperature
it's actually considered a tropical
climate
so
i just started growing stuff and it just
got so big it was unbelievable
and in terms of the perfect growing
conditions for
a pepper they need sun lots of water and
do they need a rich soil or not
well you know we're we're a red clay
based soil it's slightly acidic so i i
knocked out i knocked that down with
some calcium and magnesium and stuff
but it it's the perfect temperature mix
uh
you know when you're in a plane like
this you get you get the minerals from
the mountains you get the stuff from
that washes up from the the coast and
has been deposited so there's a really
good mixture uh
but
we don't you know our our rainfall isn't
really what what does it it's the heat
we get to put
like i start my peppers in the
greenhouse sometime around the second
week of january we're getting them in
the ground
as mature plants sometime you know
around the beginning of april and we
start harvesting in june and with our
temperatures depending on how many
hurricanes we get uh we can keep those
peppers going all the way through you
know thanksgiving christmas time so we
get to harvest
a ton more peppers than other people do
and also we do everything naturally so
we're hand-picking those peppers whereas
like industrial farms it's one and done
they pick them with the machine it
destroys the plant they don't get any
more
we're getting five to eight times the
harvest all those other plants are by
employing people and hand picking those
peppers
so then it grows again and you can
get it later in the year
what wha where do you where did the
peppers go um are you selling
like how big a
farm have you got going on there are you
selling
and locally or to all all of america or
further afield
well what we do is we turn our peppers
into some a product called peppermash
which is the base of everything hot in
the world okay anything you see at the
grocery store either as pepper powder or
pepper mash in it
so we we produce pepper mash and that
can be turned into salsa hot sauce
jerkies just about anything you see or
the dried pepper can be done the same
way
right now our company alone distributes
in 95 countries on a monthly basis
but we distribute to we also sell that
peppermash to all the major
manufacturers in the united states uh
also there's a lot of a lot of shows
that use us like there there's other uh
weekly shows like where celebrities eat
chicken wings we make hot sauce for them
there's other podcasts that we make hot
sauce for us yeah you know
it's just
hot sauce overtook ketchup mustard and
mayonnaise in the united states as the
number one condiment in 2004. people
don't realize how really big this market
is
what's what's your favorite hot sauce
my favorite hot sauce are you talking my
own hot sauce or another maker well
obviously yours is going to be your
favorite yeah surely
well you know honestly my favorite is
the reaper squeezings the extra hot
version which is somewhere around 96
pepper right
but i had a hot sauce by a company
called humboldt out there in humboldt
hot sauce out there in california this
past weekend yeah we were doing a show
in portland
and his new cannibal hot sauce was
amazing i've already been through three
bottles in the last five days
wow wow yeah it was really good and it's
not it's not really that you know to the
normal person it would be hot it's not
really that hot
uh but it was delicious and it paired
well with everything we ate in portland
well this is the thing with hot sauce
for me because i love hot sauce my wife
loves it even more than me but for me it
has to be a hot sauce that pairs well
with the food i feel some of the famous
hot sauces just overpower the food i
agree where all i can taste is a hot
sauce
but then when you go and get more local
ones or or someone who's tried to make
something special like our producer here
made some hot sauces that were fantastic
because it it sort of pairs with the
food rather than just overpowers of
flavor and just gives you heat and
nothing else you know
well you know i i always tell people i'm
i'm honest with them straight out front
when they ask me
our pepper purees
are nothing but pepper and vinegar we
don't add any chemicals we don't do
anything like that they're very very hot
so you have to use very very little when
you're pairing it with food
okay but there's we have
80 other sauces that are milder and go
well with food and you need to try those
uh because if you can't enjoy the
product you're using you shouldn't be
buying that product yeah
there are literally hundreds and
hundreds of nationwide hot sauce
companies that no one's ever heard of
that make fantastic products
uh but you you really need to go search
and farm ride for those yeah most most
of the stuff i find that they are
unfortunately offering to you in most
restaurants like you said the kind of
classic almost generic now hot sauce
is it's just overwhelming you're just
like well now my
protein or my carb just taste of the hot
sauce doesn't taste off the carb with
the hot sauce whereas you get you were
kind enough ed you've sent us a few of
your sauces which i'm really looking
forward to trying
tonight but yeah it looks like the sauce
that you that's i want that at the side
there of the plate and it's going to
help the flavor of the food as well as
giving me that
little kick of heat which both me and
don both love in our foods yeah
well though those generic hot sauces
even though they're good and they're
they're well known throughout the united
states
there's very little pepper in there
there's only about one percent pepper
and there's a whole lot of salt right uh
so that whole lot of salt and whole lot
of vinegar overpowers to me
everything that i'm trying yeah okay
when when i get stuck in a store and i
or a restaurant and the only thing they
have you know
is that
little little teeny bottle of hot sauce
yeah i'd rather go without yeah you know
it's rubbish that stuff yeah just like
we say for me
that's the only flavor i can taste
and i i'd be as well not eating the food
yeah i'd be as well just having a
spoonful of that yeah
um ed can we talk very briefly maybe at
some point we can we can start to bring
in some of the things that ed yeah has
uh offered to us
have a look but could we could you just
talk about the science of
when you
have isolated something a pepper that is
hot and then you try and marry it with
another pepper that is hot can you talk
to us about the science of how you
create a kind of spliced plant
okay well peppers are in the nightshade
family so they're self-pollinated
so if we find two different peppers that
we're trying to get the traits from both
peppers into a new one you have to start
very early in the morning when the
flowers are opening and try to transfer
a pollen from one plant to another
transfer oh as many flowers as you can
and then start pinching off all the
other flowers that come up okay so when
the fruit finally ripens from that
pepper if it's got the attributes you're
looking for from the two parental units
then you have to harvest the seeds out
of that
and replant it if the
pepper looks the same as the pepper the
next year you got you know you keep all
your data you mark mark it up if it has
the same flavor
profile if it has the same attributes if
it's if the chemistry analysis is the
same then that's the first generation
okay
uh to get something a crossbreed that is
stable
you need anywhere between eight and
twelve generations before a botanist or
geneticist will say yes it has been like
since the first year the plants are
have like attributes the peppers have
like attributes and then the chemist
comes along and says and the chemistry
of the plant is
like attribute once once all that is
done and they say it's good then you
have a stable cross breed
okay and once that stable cross period
is there then you start collecting data
so you can see
do i have everything i need in this plan
and the first thing we do is talk to you
know there's a large medical community
here we say hey we got something with a
large
you know
uh
the die the dihydrocapsaicins are really
banging on this one as compared to
normal do you want to look at it uh we
let them look at it first to see if
there's any medical application for this
uh before we start talking about the
food application yeah uh but a lot of
things you know
i supplied people with a lot of peppers
early on and they're like ed we're we
got enough right now you know
let's keep that one in in the pike until
we we we use up the last one you gave us
yeah you know so there's a lot of
peppers out there we have that have
really really good attributes that are
coming on strong
and that are just uh looking to be
maybe either the next world record or
something that might have a better
delivery method for the medical
application that we're using
say that word again sorry
you've said it a few times and it's
still not going in my small brain
the what is the the major medical begins
with a c
the one that they're doing the most
research on is cancer no they're they're
mean capsaicin yeah
capsaicin is just one of many
capsionoids
it's like a uh family okay
everybody knows capsaicin because it's
the most prevalent of the chemical
compounds that are in peppers
but there's very many minor compounds so
dihydrotetrahydro
there's there's a ton of them that the
chemists are looking at
and each of those affects a different
area of the body so those are the things
we're looking at when we're doing our
chemical analysis
unless my ego's in the way and then i'm
just looking for a total
uh spectrum to see what the shu is and
see if i want to break my own record i
try to keep that ego out of the way and
keep focused on our mission the the
medical grade of it all now also ed what
what is
what's the difference between
humans and
other animals let's say for the sake of
argument birds the
birds don't react to the quote-unquote
heat in the peppers but humans do
well there's a there's a nerve and
receptor called a trvp1 receptor
that's the receptor that uh the chemical
reaction with capsaicin
uh tricks our brain in to believing
there is heat going on there's fire
going on
there like i said before there is no
fire there is no heat it's just a
chemistry trick yeah uh only mammals
have that
so dogs cats humans
deer elephants you know mammals have
those receptors uh they have not found
those receptors in any of the other
branches
of fauna flora animals anything
so excuse me is the idea behind that
that a larger
animal might eat all of the peppers and
not move the seeds around too much
whereas something smaller like a bird
would eat some of the seeds and then fly
off over a greater distance and spread
it around do we know where do we do we
have any kind of logic understanding as
to why that's triggering in us
well uh a good friend good friend of
mine dave dewitt he's called the pope of
peppers he's done you know he's written
a few books and has a lot of research uh
about you know that's exactly what
they think happened with peppers they
were
originally from upper south america and
central america
and birds ate them and slowly they
migrated over the the routes of the
birds
uh because they it doesn't affect them
at all and birds use seeds to get things
through their gullet so that they can
keep on going helps them digest their
food yeah uh
you know a lot of people have said that
you know in india they use peppers to
keep the elephants out of farms
my you know my experience is all mammals
know that
when it's green they can eat it
and when they get to the peppers they
stop eating
and deer like for example we have a high
deer population
at one point they had a field full of
peppers 35 000 plants to the ground
but they had used
the same that same field the year before
they they got to the peppers and jumped
like they were shot ran off
didn't touch the peppers but they
figured out it was the fruit that was
causing the issue not the green leafy
yeah so they just eat the green leafy
off the plant now and they'll leave the
fruit sitting there you know amazing so
you know mammals have a little bit
higher intelligence i guess yeah because
they can pick and choose what they're
going to eat yeah but you know there's
really uh
i can't they didn't find anything in
fish or reptiles or birds
you know a lot of amphibians we they've
looked everywhere for this receptor and
it's only in mammals interesting
billy and dom eat the world
um yeah hey john can we bring some of
those things in and we'll start to kind
of explore a little bit maybe we'll uh
some of those sauces we can be brave and
maybe have a few dabs of the sauces and
then yeah i think you also actually sent
us some actual peppers now are these are
these ghost peppers or these carolina
reapers that you sent us i believe they
sent you some carolina reapers thank you
dad so which is the hottest paper in the
world at the moment is that right
correct right now guinness has it at
the record at
1.642 million scoville heat units right
but we might be up in that game in just
a month or so the scoville meter why why
the name skova was it was a scientist
called scoville who invented it yeah
wilbur scoville
uh he worked he worked for a company up
in michigan actually
and they were trying to decide how pet
how hot peppers were but it was a very
subjective scale that he used it was how
much
how much water it took for an individual
to dilute
uh pepper until they couldn't taste any
heat
but
science you know science is science and
they they develop machinery that is more
objective instead of subjective
because what i think is hot is not going
to be what you think is of course right
and it's going to take less water for me
than it is for you yeah so did you did
you set out to make the the hottest
pepper because it sounds like the the
medical side is it sounds like it's
very interesting to you but as you say
you know maybe your ego takes over as
you understand it more and more
oh well i didn't start out looking to
make the hottest pepper in the world
even though in 1981 while i was studying
for an exam i i wrote down well i didn't
actually write it down a young lady
named shelly wrote down uh what six of
us we're going to do in life that might
change the world and what i told her to
write down is i might i'm going to make
the world saddest bet
yes it was always in the back of my mind
even though i was very drunk and high at
that time
but when i when i did these crosses it
had nothing to do with i'm making the
hottest pepper it really had to do more
with raising that one capsionoid i i
truly believe
is the one that has the key that kills
cancer nice and it just turned out to be
really really really hot yeah okay okay
so we've got a california
i can't say that no coloring
caroline which is weird
i think we're i think we're getting
pushed a little bit for time so i don't
know if
we're doing the uh sauces and all that
we'll just take a now what would you you
said you're not supposed to eat these on
their own so should we just take a tiny
by head is that the idea well
it depends on how daring you are uh i
truly you know
i love you guys i'll send you whatever
sauce you want to your house but if you
eat that old pepper i'm going to be
taking over
okay so we'll just take a bite are you
ready let's do it sure okay then i just
want to see how much of a bite you take
i'm going to see that in but yeah i'm
going to take that right off
i'll do the same hang on
all right let's talk through it right
starts off so actually it's like a level
starts like a bell pepper like a
yeah it has a really sweet flavor it's a
simple sugar so i was raising those
because
my my thought behind it was that chemo
patients can taste simple sugars it's
the complex carbs that really make them
sick so if i raise the sweetness
maybe they would eat more food and not
starve to death
i agree there's some sweetness there's a
little heat coming through
a little
but nothing that's scaring me yeah no to
the extent that i'm going to take
another little bite really yeah awesome
what part of my body gets the heat as
well great question right well well all
your whole body has those receptors
right okay but what happens normally is
the oil gets stuck in your taste buds in
your tongue your your taste buds kind of
look like trees right and the oil from
the pepper gets under that taste bud
and then the chemical reaction just
starts rolling and it can't escape right
so most people perceive it on their
tongue first and then in their throat
uh but then they make the mistake of
wiping their eyes or you know
go up through the top building
go near the top
section though yeah you guys hate what
my wife calls the cheater piece it gives
you the flavor without it
because the flavor is actually really
nice yeah the flavor is still lovely
but i'm now getting the heat sauce
oh yeah
yeah yeah you get up
i took quite a lot i think you've not
taken anywhere near as well let me see
it i'll take more there i took i took
that that section that cross section
there yeah
brilliant
you guys obviously are professionals
because most people die if you if you
look at other interviews with me i i
have to take over no look we
love yeah we love hot spicy food billy
and i have a lot of very common
interests and i think one of them is
exploring new types of food and if it
can be spicy we're absolutely over the
moon about it it is
consistently getting hotter yeah i'm
getting it
in my chip
yes yes no all the hot hiccups oh yeah
so
it's it's crazy isn't it the the
the sensation of heat so there is
nothing that is heating up on our tongue
you're right bills
nothing in our mouth is actually getting
hotter
just a chemical yeah
you perceive as heat you know uh like
my favorite things with the reaper
are uh indian food
it pairs so well with indian food
vindaloo yeah yeah vindaloo is amazing
yeah
yeah vindaloo's incredible oh billy
you're really feeling that one
are you getting hot lips
i know it's like my whole
have a little bit of water maybe
i'm going
to no don't don't drink water it's just
going to make it worse oh well ed here's
a question because i've been desperately
trying to get on that show hot ones
hopefully with billy at some point and
at this point this is way too easy for
you to eat something else it's
definitely spicy
at this point we've not we've not been
able to go on the show but
what would you say if you eat something
hot and you want to cool it down should
you drink milk should you
should you eat ice what should you eat
what should you do well
see every time i watch people chug milk
to get rid of heat they think the fat is
going to break up the oils and stuff
they wind up drinking a half gallon of
milk and then they throw up and say oh
that's damn pepper made me throw up it's
not the pepper you're not supposed to
drink a half gallon of milk at once
disperse the oil me personally i use
citric acid uh-huh
like grapefruit juice or lime juice or
lemon juice citric acid
yeah it slows it down
so it doesn't make it go away it just
slows down the reaction don't think we
have citric acid but um so in an ideal
world you would what squeeze a lemon and
then you drink like pure lemon juice
yeah or i i just take a piece of lime
and start chewing on it or whatever
but really it's all a matter of time
okay
some people it takes 10 minutes some
people it takes 20. you know i feel like
i can feel a pulse in the back of my
head now i love this this is my favorite
show ever like my head is like
like i feel as if my headphones are
going like this yeah yeah kind of like
you did some nitrous oxide or something
but i tell you what ed you had mentioned
earlier on about the
euphoria the high
i mean i've got
my whole mouth and my lips are on fire
but my brain feels like it's kind of
zipping a little faster than normal
maybe maybe it's because my mate billy's
almost about to pass out it could be
that the experience
i mean
it's definitely
i mean it's it's hot to the point that
it's doing something to my body that
no other uh
pepper's ever done you know i've never
felt that pulsating incredible you know
i've had hot things with like indian
food where my nose
runs but yeah
that's a different feeling
guess what guys now that you've had a
hit
i'm just like the other dealers you're
going to have to keep on coming
i'm sure you've heard this a lot ed but
i've never had this before i've got hot
teeth and hot gums all of my
gums are roasting hot and my teeth feel
hot so out of the amazing gift that you
gave us of those uh carolina reapers
what would you say would be a good thing
for us to do because you don't recommend
us eating them raw could we could you
talk us through a kind of simple hot
sauce that we could make at home or a
chutney or something like that
oh sure that just real simple yeah take
take those peppers
uh just any normal blender okay yeah
take those peppers put them in the
blender
add maybe a cup of vinegar
a couple cloves of garlic a half an
onion maybe a full onion if you really
like onion
uh some turmeric some uh
black pepper
and and then something to offset it like
uh
say cinnamon or nutmeg or you know one
of those one of those other more base
spices and just give it a quick blend
let it sit for a couple days and
you're gonna have an amazing hot sauce
and is that something that stays does it
does does the heat in the hot sauce
preserve the sauce or is there a shelf
life
no no
the the pepper is a fruit just like any
other fruit it has no preservation
values at all it's the vinegar there
that's going to preserve it by putting
you know that amount of vinegar in
you're going to get a ph lower than say
4.0 or 3.8 and then it's good for
anywhere between you know five and eight
years my soft palate it's moved to my
soft palate now
that
that's pulsating
yeah you're gonna get all sorts of body
experience some people have actually
said my arms feel like they're floating
you know yeah and that's that huge
amount of endorphins flowing through the
body yeah i wonder if i feel a little
lighter than normal but yeah it
definitely has affected me in that way
yes at this point it's generally
localized around my mouth tongue teeth
gums all that kind of stuff does it
later on move through the digestive
system like that or does it lose it oh
yes it's going to move down into your
chest and then when it gets to your
stomach you might get a little bit of a
cramp kind of akin to a menstrual cramp
and then and then depending on your
system
anywhere between 12 and 24 hours you're
going to experience something called
ring sting
when it exits out the other side talk me
through that when that happens i'll let
you know but i mean
the most exciting thing i think from
this conversation it's been lovely
talking to you yeah by the way but no
it's been an honor guys you're the the
medical side is so interesting
incredible i can totally see your
passion for it
yeah and and
i think what you were saying about you
know cancer patients and stuff i think
you you should write that down because i
think you you're
you'll get somewhere with that you know
in the same way that you wrote down
i'm going to get the hottest
paper ever
well you know uh the pharmaceutical
industry does not like people knowing
about natural cures do anything yeah
okay
uh so the attorneys every time i talk to
people like this the attorneys call me
up and say oh you shouldn't have said
that you shouldn't have said that but i
i don't really care we got to get the
message out there that there's
alternatives to things and that's why
the people studying them don't publish
much they there is a lot that has been
published like the first time i was on
tv
i had no idea one of the places i was
sending peppers to was a research
facility in sloan kettering and they
also had one of the researchers on who
said yep he's right you know and i i had
no idea that they were doing that
because everything is blind okay we send
it to
whoever asked for it you know and i had
no idea he was a cancer researcher at
sloan kettering all right but he tested
all of my hypotheses he looked at the
research i had done and said this man is
right and we announced that on the cbs
news one morning
in new york and it never went anywhere
no one ever no one else ever asked about
it it's incredibly incredibly
interesting i mean most pharmaceuticals
i mean it comes from plants anyway right
i mean most of them
so this has got to be studied more hey
i'm gonna have another bite oh yeah i
want to see it it's hot you dealt with
that so well no no i was struggling i
feel like you should look how much i had
i'm not definitely not finishing that do
that i had a whole bit no do the whole
thing do it
i i'm honestly not my enough now ed you
you could eat the whole thing yeah no
problem well i was just at that expo
that i told you about in portland i had
to eat them for tv i had to eat them for
you know we had customers who come up
who say let's eat a reaper together if
that guy comes and eats a whole pepper i
can't just take a bite i gotta eat a
whole pepper too sure and you you have
the same sensations heat in the mouth
you get you get sweaty and all that kind
of stuff just not the same level that
we've experienced
no i i experience everything
physiologically that everybody else
experiences
i'm it's just like say the alcoholic you
know uh some people one beer knocks them
on their ass some people a hundred beers
doesn't phase them so my body has
developed a tolerance to the point where
i can keep on talking afterwards
but inside i'm getting the cramps my
mouth is water and my eyes are watering
and all the same stuff happens because
there's really when they say mind over
matter that that doesn't work as far as
peppers go yeah yeah no there's nothing
you can do it's gonna it's gonna have an
effect on you right i thought well i'll
just breathe through it and it'll be
fine but
that i think that's probably the hottest
thing though zed says it's uh it's a
chemical thing so your body's just
dealing with chemicals right it's not
yeah it's not something yeah it's
dealing with the chemical reaction
nothing more but in terms of the mouth
tongue gum thing it seems to leave after
around about eight to ten minutes it's
tapering off for you now yeah i've got
it it's just on my sort of um
that soft palate
is really sort of stingy um but other
than that but i mean i i i lost control
they talk i couldn't talk i saw that
when that first
first bite have you seen the show hot
ones ed i make all their hot sauce oh
you should put in a good word for billy
and i we would love to do that show
yeah they're really good friends of mine
i'll actually be talking to them in the
mornings i'll put it in tell them we're
massive fans of hot sauce and we'd love
to do the show did you bring in a couple
of those hot sauces especially if it's
your hot sauce ed so that becomes a kind
of curated hot sauce from relatively
mild to pretty hot yeah
yeah i actually make their mildest sauce
the classic and i also make their
hottest sauce oh the last dab on yep and
usually everything in between ah
so
let's have a look so what have we got
let's try at least one you've got bacon
me crazy
and we've got
we've got the voodoo prince
okay and we have got hold on
put your bloody glasses on
uh
the reaper which one should be true
why don't you try
uh the voodoo prince or the bacon me
crazy because
is there bacon in baking
yeah i don't eat bacon so let's do the
let's do the voodoo prince right voodoo
prince hot sauce um death mamba
death mamba they
i like the artwork we've also got thank
you so much for sending these sources
said that's so generous we've also got
there
would it am i saying this right the the
russia
rapture r-a-c-h-a russia
reaperacha paracha
we've got el tefe taco verde and we've
got what looks like one of your ones
peyton's hot strawberry from the
pocketbook company
yeah that strawberry one is fresh
strawberries from our farm and some
peppers
i'm just giving this a dab done oh yeah
do it a dab now what on your finger
i haven't got nothing else
have you got a little spin now john
you can chug it
i love it
it's not hot the one you're trying has
some ghost pepper in it
a little bit of garlic
onion cumin and black pepper oh yeah i
can smell the cumin
yeah well it's such a fun thing you do
oh that's fantastic
this is the patent hot strawberry so you
get quite a lot of sweetness and then
the heat coming through afterwards
that's fantastic
that tastes so good on ice cream it's
unbelievable
i'll just taste it like this
we've got chips if you want on tom yeah
william right i'm trying this voodoo
prince okay and i'll swap you for the
you've got you have to try this payton
hot strawberry now ed before we let you
go where can people get hold of your hot
sauce from the puckerbot
well our website is www.dot
brilliant uh we're available at a lot of
stores i mean
the best price you're going to get is on
our website because
i'm an idiot and i'm always giving stuff
away good for
good for you i love your attitude to all
this it's great just getting somebody on
who's obviously passionate about what
they do
and then i've yeah i couldn't make up my
life if i tried my life is so good oh
good for you man i get to play with
peppers all day long every single day
i love the i love the black pepper vibe
in that voodoo prince
delicious that's lovely this is exactly
what i'm talking about good on a steak
though you know the hot sauce when it's
just got a nice flavor and it's going to
help the food yeah and it brings that
heat that's what you're wanting
absolutely we'll put your website at the
bottom of them of this so that people
can see where to get it but hey that was
interesting yeah
it's been absolutely fantastic having
you on if you feel inclined to give the
hot ones people a nudge i've been trying
to get on that show for about three
years and they're like well we're a bit
too big time and i'm like oh but what
about two hobbits would be great
yeah i won't approach it that way i'll
say my friends want to be on the show i
said reach out to him nice ed that was
fantastic brilliant having you on uh
keep up the good work we look forward to
hearing more and more about what you're
up to in the uh
in the pepper world and yeah and i'm
certainly going to read up more on the
medical side of it that's that's
incredible stuff um yeah it's really
really awesome what's going on yeah cool
well have a wonderful rest of your day
ed it's lovely to meet you lovely spend
time with you take it easy thank you
very much all right take care guys good
to see you bye
bye that was amazing and one what a
reaction i mean
like you had said there's nothing you
can do right you try as hard as you can
to kind of
just breathe your way through it and go
oh yep that's that's definitely hot but
after a certain amount of time
your system just kind of goes you need
to be quiet for a moment and deal with
what's going on and then as i was just
saying through the window there dom i
think there's somebody else in the
studio who should try it out well not
only has johnny clues made his own hot
sauces well he's he's a master he's a
hot sauce aficionado now john as as you
might have seen billy and i started with
the little tip i think you should start
with the tip because that will give you
the pepper flavor you get the flavor
then so you know it's so lovely and then
take a little bite from the top area
i'm a little nervous it's like no and
it's not it's not something that you
can't handle but
try the tip so you get that kind of
almost kind of red pepper bell pepper
taste we'll give it a score well while
you're um yeah and then you can score it
how's your mate is your mate working
check check yeah it's working just
working yeah my hands are shaking yeah
you're all good seeing billy there
like watching this
at the moment at the moment all right so
i'm gonna do this little tip
now that just tastes like a pepper
really it's kind of
sweet maybe a little bit of heat but not
really right
um see the flavor though it's nice yeah
it's like a fresh it's like a red pepper
and then if you go closer to where then
you have to go down
to where the stem is
then you then you'll immediately be like
oh okay it's almost like a completely
different thing so right in the side
yeah yeah those alone take the side out
we've already take this
oh my god
he's worried though my sand is shaking
it's not that bad
[Laughter]
all right
all right that's good
all right was that a good chunk is that
a good
oh yeah yeah but your glasses just
steamed up
my ears were sweating i took off my
headphones and my ears were sweating
yeah it's hot isn't it john
yeah so we'll keep brightening your up
mm-hmm
yeah but there is like a fruitiness oh
yes a little sweetness coming through
and then
it goes hot in different places my teeth
started getting hot at one point
oh my gosh yeah this feels like well
billy while john deals with that for a
second should we give it scores yeah
well for the flavor that little top part
that's a delicious pepper flavor and i
have to give that a 9.3 wow for the hot
crazy hot yeah not for the actual flavor
the flavor the taste yeah
i'm gonna say i mean it was hot i'm
gonna but i loved it too
uh
i'll give it an 8.2
give it give it a score for flavor
flavor
nine point
oh yeah bottom part i'll give that a
little tip i'll give that
add a little bit lovely flavor i'm gonna
eat 0.9
you've got water there if you need it
john don't worry you've got milk i'm
sure billy
the hot part pants
it is fruity you know it's really 9.4
oh not bad yeah nice no aesthetics i
quite like it it's a it's a cute little
uh cheeky orange number and it's got a
strange little tip on it yeah
it looks like a devil's hat
good look love that color i love it uh
i'm like a dehydrated pepper i'm gonna
give it a
an eight it's a good score
um how i like the look of it as well
damn i'm having another bite go on yeah
are you really i'll give it an 8.2 damn
how did you sit here the whole time just
like
yeah just chat
chat it's hot but i like to really be in
the thicker things and just see how i
can i'm sweating look
i can see on the screen i'm sweating
john's sweating his eyes are sweating
yeah
don't just be careful about touching
your eyes yeah don't touch your eyes if
you um
billy did you give it score for the look
i did john what about the look do you
like look i'm gonna go nine point eight
well he likes it he's loving it because
it looks kind of friendly yeah
how useful is it well
you've got your hot sauces you've got
all your medical significance my god
that's incredible
it's good i mean and food wise
i mean ed was saying it's the most
popular thing that people have
on the table now not not ketchup or
mustard or mayo and
it's gone around the world peppers that
pepper taste has gone around the world
and if you put it in a food processor as
he said some vinegar a little bit of
garlic onions and you want you make your
own sauce as our friend uh johnny clues
tells us john looks like he's been
kicked in the balls have you john that
is an experience
feeling like now what was he crying he's
like he wants to speak yeah he's crying
uh usefulness i i can't give it a
perfect 10 but i'm going to give it
pretty close i'm going to give it a 9.7
i'm going gonna give as a usefulness
i'm gonna give it a 9.9 wow
i mean it's incredibly useful isn't it
john
that's very useful that is um
feels like my stomach's sweating yeah
there's hot i feel it like right in
there right
uh uh what did you ask me
how useful is it useful
i mean this would be a fun like hey how
about you you try this
you know like to somebody
at a party yeah you know hey yeah yeah
everybody have a bite of this i was once
on a date with a girl in college oh god
i was like let me buy
we're gonna make spaghetti
i'm gonna get some peppers you know
these cute little orange ones are so
cute why don't we put these in there
i didn't know they're habaneros and uh
up until this moment that was the
biggest mistake
or experience i've ever had
wow
it's hot john you're crying i'm crying
john you're poor angel don't touch your
eyes whatever you do for us yeah it's
like it's the stomach i feel like uh
like the endorphins you're right it is
this like throbby
yeah billy billy had hot hiccups and
i've never seen you have hot hiccups no
some people use the whole thing what
people just i've seen videos of people
yeah that's going crazy i feel like we
should all finish the episode by doing
that i've recently bit my tongue
and it's actually helping the tongue
area where it's been bitten it's like
created a little pain killing thing
there good on you john for coming in i
appreciate you part of the team thank
you well billy i think it's milk i think
we've run out of time let's let's close
the show with john here just suffering
between us can we
i know we were going to split those 50
50 but i think we should do a third day
because i think john could make us a
source from that i agree that would be
to die for
potentially maybe literally yeah yeah i
would love to do that that's what i was
singing the whole time would you do the
thing with the mango again do you think
yeah needs a sweetness to cut into it
guys we can't wait that's going to be on
how long will that take you these uh
i'll probably do four weeks right i
start today
maybe we'll do it when dom's back i also
think inside those peppers will
obviously be seeds and you can plant
some yourself oh oh god
we've ran out of time but we'll see you
next week make sure that you uh keep
sending your fan out to us and uh you
can get in touch with us
you can get touches on our youtube page
or you can leave questions comments and
concerns where you pick up the podcast
rate review and subscribe to us anything
else leave a voice message leave a voice
message at speakpipe.com forward slash
the friendship onion and don't forget to
get the merchandise wear the t-shirts or
make you sexy like johnny clues you get
that at the friendshiponionpodcast.com
see you next week toodles
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me back to go
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy
[Music]